well a new program to help entrepreneurs
in our state has just rolled out and you
still have some time to apply for this
one it's called incubate Vegas looking
to help Founders who have been
traditionally underserved we're talking
women minorities and veterans
I've been working on the business myself
for a little over a year now and it's
just kind of hard to get going obviously
I don't know everything Las Vegas native
Shannon Hanks is starting her own
collections agency she's in the pre-seed
startup phase looking to raise some
Capital
getting some big time help by attending
this free course offered by startup NV
called the incubate Vegas program she
applied was chosen as one of 25 to
attend a 10-week course held every
Saturday I helped somebody else launch a
collection agency and worked in
management and I've always had an
entrepreneur mindset and so at some
point I was just like I could do this
for myself we teach entrepreneurs about
how to be Founders how to raise Capital
you know how to put a proper business
plan together that's probably something
that's better than financing than
Adventure Time co-founder and executive
director Jeff sailing says incubate
Vegas is similar to other programs
offered through startup and V but this
one offers help to those who have been
traditionally underserved women
minorities veterans have not enjoyed as
much attention in the startup ecosystem
as you know the percentage that they
perhaps represent in the in the
population in general so we're going to
try to to solve that or at least at
least make it better Shannon is grateful
for the opportunity I'm excited for like
the mentorship and the networking make
sure that I have all my ducks in a row
and I'm doing things the right way so
that I am more success successful going
forward
we do want to let you know that startup
envy and Clark County offers this for
the next two years hopes to help at
least 100 Founders the program funded by
a Federal grant that Clark County
received you can apply now for the next
free seminar which starts up again in
September